criminal charges may soon be recommended
against a former trump adviser by the
house select committee investigating the
january 6 attack they're looking for
answers about what led a pro-trump mob
to invade the capitol that day and
they're accusing steve bannon remember
him of defying a congressional subpoena
bannon is trying to claim executive
privilege a rather expansive sort of it
because he has not been in the white
house for years nicole killian is
following all this for us on capitol
hill nicole good morning to you a lot of
twists and turns
yeah absolutely tony and next week the
select committee will vote on whether to
hold steve bannon in contempt of
congress the former white house chief
strategist was a no-show for a
deposition yesterday the day before he
attended a rally in virginia where some
pledged allegiance to a flag allegedly
carried by rioters on january 6.
bannon's attorney said his client will
not be producing documents or testifying
until the committee reaches an agreement
with former president trump over the
scope of executive privilege the
committee said we reject his position
entirely and will not tolerate defiance
of our subpoenas the biden
administration has refused to honor mr
trump's claims of executive privilege so
it could set the stage for a fight the
full house will have to approve sending
this criminal referral to the justice
department the committee wants to make
clear that there will be consequences
for not cooperating nate
nicole thank you